on a un individu tout à fait déterminé
qui refuse de s'arrêter qui percute la
voiture des collègues et on sait
évidemment que dans sa fuite il va soit
tué des passants comme s'était récemment
le cas dans plusieurs affaires le site
duratorq du restaurateur qui a été tuée
par un chauffard tant d'autres
s'affairent qu on pourrait citer
effectivement le collègue vous l'avez
dit avec beaucoup de justesse m il ya eu
une réforme il ya un texte qui permet à
mes collègues d'ouvrir le feu le
collègue a fait preuve de beaucoup de
discernement il a évité des morts il a
évité d'autres morts il a tiré
l'individu a choisi il aurait pu
s'arrêter il a continué le collègue a
tiré et je pense qu'il faut pas tomber
dans l'inversion comme vous le faites
alors est-ce
qu'il était dans la presse il ya des
infos qui ont circulé comme qu'elle
circulait sans permis à bord d'un
véhicule moi moi moi je n'ai pas accès
au dossier donc je rentrerai pas là
dessus et pas moi je juge sur les faits
qui se sont produits on voit que cet
individu a refusé d'obtempérer il était
déterminé il a percuté la voiture de
police le collègues étaient tout à fait
fondés à attirer la preuve la justice va
aujourd'hui dans son sens en ne mettant
pas en cause pour homicide volontaire
simplement pour violences quant à voir
la vidéo
[Musique]
on y tient
ça tire ça tire
[Musique]
à
on
hopu tient
à des images voilà
c'est compliqué de revoir ces images
donc pour vous là il a eu la bonne
attitude je pense qu'il faut arrêter
d'inverser les valeurs aujourd'hui la
véritable victime dans cette affaire
c'est mon collègue imaginez le
traumatisme que c'est aujourd'hui pour
le collègue d'avoir ouvert le feu les
avocats l'ont rappelé le collègue était
en état de choc après après avoir ces
feux ont subi aujourd'hui en france un
refus d'obtempérer toutes les 30 minutes
nous sommes le seul pays aujourd'hui
parmi les pays les plus avancés en
termes de droits de l'homme je pense
notamment à nos confrères anglais c'est
que mes collègues en angleterre
aujourd'hui ils appliquent le contact
tactique sur les refus d'obtempérer il
shoote avec le véhicule avec les risques
que cela peut avoir il faut aujourd'hui
que les individus apprennent à s'arrêter
à obtempérer aux forces de l'ordre on ne
peut pas continuer en france en laissant
tout faire vous savez que notre
hiérarchie aujourd'hui nous interdit de
prendre en chasse les véhicules ça veut
dire qu'on est dans une situation
aujourd'hui d' impunité absolue un
individu refuse de s'arrêter il peut
transporter de la drogue il peut avoir
commis un braquage il peut être dans une
action terroriste on ne peut pas le
prendre en chasse dont un moment donné
il faut que les choses s'arrêtent mon
organisation syndicale le syndicat
france police policiers en colère nous
on y dit pour une réforme de la légitime
défense on estime aujourd'hui que le
texte ne va pas assez loin il faut
retirer du texte de notion celle de
proportionnalité et d'absolue nécessité
qui sont des notions absolument floués
qui laisse la porte à toutes les
interprétations jurisprudentielles à qui
la justice chico dit quoi aujourd'hui la
justice à leur connaît évidemment la
légitime défense pour le lycée alors
allez avoir une manageuse fonctionne à
corps et à voir la justice ne reconnaît
absolument pas pour l'instant légitime
défense il aurait de l'émir aux causes
non aujourd'hui il est mise en examen
pour violences ayant entraîné la mort
sans intention de la donner a omis la
victime défense d'accord mis si
longtemps que ça c'est la première des
choses deuxièmement vous savez très bien
quand on suit un dossier judiciaire il
ya un fort risque de requalification et
a2 beaucoup de dossiers voyage y
commence à s les mains terminer monsieur
petit commence notamment de cette façon
et qui se termine par la qualification
d'homicide volontaire et ça vous le
savez très bien et là quand vous dites
quand j'entends monsieur touriste et je
vous entends dire il faudrait enlever
ces notions un peu flou l'absolue
nécessité la stricte proportionnalité
qu'est-ce que vous demander monsieur
touristes habitué à la française que
vous demandera toujours on doit tuer mon
âme ans 11,2 si monsieur effectivement
les sirènes sont encadrés par ces
solutions personnalité qui va dire à ce
moment là qui va encadrer à quel moment
on peut tirer et on peut prendre la vie
d'une personne parce que concrètement
c'est ce qui s'est passé tirer
aujourd'hui prendre le risque de tirer
c'est prendre le risque d'enlever la vie
d'une personne et d'ailleurs cette
indécence parce qu'aujourd'hui monsieur
touriste nous paraît effectivement
extrêmement oppose etc cyril encore une
fois je dis comme cet important et pour
rebondir sur ce qu'a dit tout à l'heure
mon confrère l'inversement la victime
c'est celui qui est mort est ce que vous
savez monsieur touriste quelle est la
peine aujourd'hui du refus d'obtempérer
quelle est la peine mais c'est un
problème si elle est l'axé un problème
dans le problème de la peine est en
prenant la peine de un an et de 7500
euros d'amendé d'accord il à dire que le
rejet polluant mais répète bien acceptée
en danger de la vie d'autrui aujourd'hui
une conduite sans permis pour un refus
d'obtempérer et je veux bien entendre
tout ce qu'on veut mais personne ne me
fera croire ici qu'il n'a pas des
connaissances qui parfois ont conduit en
état d'alcooliques ont fait désirer gens
s'appuient sur des erreurs les gens se
sont pas arrêtés ont pu effectivement
dépassé le taux d'alcoolémie qui cédera
alors ici la famille dia dit une chose
que il y ait eu une procédure judiciaire
que ce dernier pu être traduits en
justice mais qu'on laisse au moins la
possibilité aux parents de continuer en
brasse et l'oignon frais vous n'étiez sa
gouaille et donatien et la maire de grey
pour une peine d'un an c'est extrêmement
grave est et j'ajoute à cela ces
touristes le fait qu'aujourd'hui sa
demeure et si elle avait également fait
ils sont rares et nous laisse croire aux
gens qu'ils ont continué à dire parce
que effectivement parce que il a fallu
courir ce crime policiers parce que
c'est un crime policiers et on a
commencé effectivement à charge et zied
en disant si elle serait peut-être aussi
un passeur de migrants etc etc je tiens
à dire un certain de choses tout d'abord
nous avons un certain nombre
d'informations que nous allons
communiquer au juge d'instruction
après c'est de communiquer là dessus
nous avons un certain nombre
d'informations qui contredisent
totalement cette thèse quant aux face à
la façon d'appréhender
zyed quant à la façon d'appréhender y
est il ya vous avez fait référence à
d'autres pays et notamment effectivement
au sein d'un tiers il ya les italiens et
les français mais vous savez comment ils
essaient d'arrêter en tirant entre dans
le tas il et on aurait pu effectivement
est d'autant plus qu'on on a vous avez
repasser la vidéo tire dans le tas on
voit que la voiture est bloquée on
aurait pu crever les pneus on aurait pu
voir c'est ce qu'ils voient c'est ici je
vais quand même vous répondre sur cette
aberration dès de crever on a beaucoup
de gens qui lisent ça on ne vit jamais
dans les pneus pour une raison simple
déjà c'est pas évident de toucher le
pneu et si le collègue tire à côté
l'ogive va poursuivre sa course et on va
abattre un passant ou n'est pas au far
west d'accord donc le tir on demande à
l'individu de s'arrêter si à un moment
donné on rentre dans le cadre de la
légitime défense le collègue chez feu
c'est qu'on tire pas dans les pneus on
tire pas dans les banques ont tiré dans
le thorax mais pas dans l'autre ne si je
comprends bien votre logique fonctionne
pas dans les pneus c'est pas prévu au
niveau administratif tiré sur la terre
il vaut mieux tirer dans la tête ou dans
le thorax alors qu'il faisait sa vie
d'ailleurs y compris au sein de votre
réglementation notre fonctionnalité que
vous l'enlever et notamment l'appui
d'une nécessité mais justement ça qui
encadrent et qui fait en sorte qu'on
fait savoir hier merci m